make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
when it when it comes to to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe a thing that really
kind of kicked this off we should start
with with Professor X the person who's
cast and that as that role is going to
be the character that basically lays the
groundwork for like why we believe that
the other characters who are playing
those characters are brought into the
x-men in the first place right so it's
gonna be one of these things where it's
kind of like you know we look to him
where we say okay it makes sense that he
would bring in you know Wolverine into
into like the x-men are something like
that and then who it is a place
wolverine would have to mesh with this
character so i would say it all really
kind of starts there and so I've given
this a lot of thought and really been
kind of mulling this over for the last
little while um and and one of the
things I want to talk about here is
Patrick Stewart under normal
circumstances I would say just bring him
back
right I mean spoilers for spider-man far
from home um JK Simmons comes back as
Jay jonah Jameson so you can do that
right you could say okay you know JK
Simmons comes back from like the Sony
side of the spider-man franchise and now
he's in the MCU and plays that character
but the difference between between
Jameson and and Xavier is that Xavier
got a sim doff and Logan right like that
was basically the end of it it was it
was the end of his character it was like
okay this character progression is done
this is the logical conclusion of his
story he's no longer part of the x-men
and in reality because the way the
send-off was done and because it was
done so exceedingly well I almost kind
of don't want him to come back right
because it would have felt like the
entire progression of Xavier as we
followed it and then like the logical
end of his character was all for nothing
and I feel like it would it would kind
of suck to see that happen so as much as
I love the character of Patrick Stewart
and as much as I think he is kind of the
definitive Professor Xavier I wouldn't
be on on par with bringing him back so
here's my first choice I actually had to
make notes so that I could that's all I
could I could get through this in one
piece not rambling all over the place my
first choice here is Bryan Cranston and
the reason why I say Bryan Cranston is
because he's a very very dynamic actor
right I mean Cranston and he's really
kind of one of a really really popular
choice him in the second character that
I have are two really popular choices to
play the role of Xavier but I think
Cranston could pull it off and the
reason why is because of malcolm in the
middle' and Breaking Bad right now those
are two of like his big roles I mean you
saw him like the Godzilla movie and and
he was cool there but in reality the the
God like his character in the Godzilla
movie would was like you know what if
Walter White was a scientist and that's
really kind of how he appeared in the
film now I love this because of the fact
that
I think he was more more identifiable as
as like Walter White and Breaking Bad
and he was is like the dad of malcolm
and malcolm in the middle' what those
two roles have shown with regards to
bryan cranston in in knock him in the
middle and in Breaking Bad is that he
can be a comedian he can play like a
funny character somebody that you don't
really take that seriously but then he
can also play a super serious guy
who's not only serious but also like
dangerous right because those are guys
who follow Breaking Bad the transition
from Walter White to Heisenberg was the
stuff of legend I mean that show was
incredible like all the seasons it was
it was amazing to watch him progress
from a guy who was just like you who was
like a science teacher they got the
worst news ever
temperature running like the biggest
drug empire in like the country right I
mean it was it was kind of great one out
a little out the biggest but to have
that big of a hand to have that big of a
transition to become that dark um when
it comes to Xavier in the comics one of
the things that Fox kind of got wrong or
gonna really got wrong but so much has
didn't really hit on all that often is
that that when you looked at Patrick
Stewart Xavier was just kind of like a
kindly guy right he was kind of okay
he's like a wise old guy who's tried to
steer the x-men to greatness know in the
comics he's a dick like he did he's kind
of an [ __ ] and like that'sthat's the
way his character always was right like
he was manipulative to a degree he would
kind of screw people over he was always
doing things for what he thought was the
right thing to do even if it meant
leaving the x-men hanging that's one of
the reasons why I'm post decimation
after the events of hustling em when
Xavier his van is when he's gone for
however long and then he returns and
Cyclops and Emma Frost have been running
the x-men all that time the sock hops
like we all need you because with you
not being here we saw how the x-men
should run versus how they were under
your direction and like you're kind of a
dick so like go away like that was that
was really sort of the direction that
that Marvel was taking they're taking
the character um the whole idea behind
the Illuminati different things like
that so Xavier was kind of conniving and
kind of manipulative to a degree and I
think Cranston could pull that off not
only that Xavier sort of has this kind
of commanding persona right like we
would like there's there's a really good
instance in Brian Michael Bendis --is
Illuminati miniseries when they're
talking about reforming the Infinity
Gauntlet and when they capture them at
the end of the story Reed Richards is
like seduced by like this power of the
Infinity Gauntlet and almost succumbs to
it and like The Watcher appears and the
Watchers like Reed you have to stop and
he's like but like to power though and
like Xavier uses this telepathy to like
overpower the mind of read and like
subtly trick him
and a believing he doesn't want and then
Reid puts the gauntlet away and you only
know that because like at the end of the
issue like they're kind of zooms in on
Xavier face and it's like he's the
reason why Reid gave it up but using
that kind of manipulative tactic is
actually sort of cool and it's actually
pretty interesting so I think Cranston
could really do well with with giving us
a sort of Charles Xavier that's somewhat
manipulative and then also sort of of
commanding and and dark to a degree now
where Bryan Cranston I think would play
more of like a rough version of Xavier
which is to say more kind of rough
around the edges and doing what he
believes to be done and and even almost
militaristic to a degree the the actor
marks strong I think would bring a more
like nuanced version of Charles Xavier
right because Mark Strong if you saw him
in the in the Kingsmen movies um he's
really more of like a kind of an
assistant almost coming at Alfred s
character in terms of the role that he
plays but he's really more sort of not
really jovial but like a guy who's sort
of light more lighthearted
but if you look at him as like the
villain in the original not really the
original I guess and the remake of the
Sherlock Holmes movies with with with
Robert Downey jr. and so I think that if
you take a character like Mark Strong
who really seems to be a little more
polished then like Brian I'm sorry not
Brian Michael Bendis then Brian Cranston
is who seems not as rough around the
edges not as rough Rogen raw I think
that that would be more like a nuanced
version of Xavier but at the same time
again Mark Strong can do a lot of the
same things to Bryan Cranston camp you
know he could play a very manipulative
and even a very very dark version of
Charles Xavier where these kind of
hidden agendas and things like that that
we're not readily aware of ah but again
I think both of those those two guys
right here would do an amazing job of
playing the character of Charles Xavier
but the third guy and this one I think
is probably gonna be a little
questionable to some people it's Sir Ben
Kingsley and the reason why Sir Ben Cage
they would actually bring a kind of pomp
and circumstance to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that really hasn't appeared
there before but that's a dangerous game
because when it comes to the MCU one of
the reasons why I left out character is
like like you know Daniel day-lewis
who's a popular choice to play Charles
Xavier is because that's kind of a super
high caliber level of actor but I think
the Marvel Cinematic Universe doesn't
really mean I think the great thing
about the MCU is that while you have
actors Hans are ye well you could look
at somebody like Sir Ben Kingsley who is
an Academy award-winning actor and who's
played some incredible roles he's also
extremely dynamic in terms of his acting
ability he has a
very very wide range and so I think he
could play off a believable Xavier but
he'd be able to play more of an Xavier
who's kind of like a wiser guy right
almost a kinder Patrick Stewart where
he's been around the block a few times
where he's really more of like a kind of
guiding hand for Xavier almost almost
like Martin Luther King in terms of how
Xavier was originally design and sort of
envisioned by by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
when he was created as opposed to the
more dynamic version that we saw under
like Chris Claremont and like the riders
that came after a Chuck Chuck Liddell
and Chuck Austin and Grant Morrison and
all these three guys and soon to be
Jonathan Hickman in terms of like the
original appearance of his character I
think Sir Ben Kingsley would be able to
bring a more kind of wise wiser and more
experienced version of Xavier but that
could or could not work out and the
reality is that it really depends on the
version of Xavier that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe goes with if they end
up going with the ultimate universe
version of Charles Xavier well he was a
new mutant just like everybody else and
he was flying by the seat of his pants
it just happened to be that he sat down
and said we need a team of mutants out
there to basically help with everything
that's going on but if they decide to go
with the Marvel against the main Marvel
Universe version of Charles Xavier who's
been around for a little while who's
been in like a war and different things
like that who fought in the Korean War
where he met Erik Lehnsherr who went on
to become Magneto if they decide to grab
that version and then say like he's been
around for like a few know for a long
time for like a couple decades or a few
decades you know in terms of knowing
what his powers were and and being able
to use those powers for various various
you know possibilities um then you can
get a more experienced and wiser version
the other downside to using sir benkei's
Lee here is that he's an older guy and
what what the Marvel Cinematic Universe
needs is an actor who can play the
character of Xavier for the foreseeable
future
right who could play it like for the
next ten years if not maybe more
depending on you know what direction
they you know what direction they want
to take the x-men and assuming that we
don't see them for like another five to
ten years then it needs to be an actor
who in five to ten years can believably
play the character and I think Mark
Strong and and and Bryan Cranston are
both young enough that they could pull
it off and you didn't kill off Xavier
has happen a multitude of times that's
one of the things that set the stage for
Cyclops to take over as leader of the
x-men which i think is a logical
conclusion for the role of Xavier in the
MCU is for him to die off and then a
cyclops to take over as leader of the
team possibly even follow the main
Marvel Universe chronology and Marvel
Comics that he becomes more militaristic
and almost like an
- classic Magneto in terms of how he
leads the x-men but uh but the fact
remains the following that you know
following Sir Ben Kingsley and in kind
of the glitter and the glitz and glamour
and the kind of Academy Award winning
title that goes along with that with
that with that kind of guy um I don't
really know what he's like behind the
scenes it could be he's like Edward
Morton right I mean if those guys who
don't know when Edward Norton played the
original Incredible Hulk or I guess
played Incredible Hulk in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe version one of the
reasons why they cut him loose is
because the rumor was really he was like
a drama queen
right like everybody had to cater to the
whims and wants of Edward Norton and
while he has played some incredible
roles over the course of his acting
history the reality of this is that it
is an Edward Norton right I mean he's
these he's a great actor but certainly
not a not a person that I think has the
ability to go on to the set of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe say hey look
like everybody should do what I want to
do because I'm Edward Norton I think
that's that's that's kind of lame but it
may be this are being Ben Kingsley's
like that I've never really looked into
it from what I hear from what I've you
know from the you know a little bit of
surface investigation I've done it guys
you know after he's been around for a
long time and it's great to work with
but I don't really know but that leads
us into my final choice here who I think
might be a little bit controversial to
some people and that's Ian McShane now
he makes Shane foes you guys don't know
who he is most of you guys will
recognize him from the John wick movies
right the guy who was who is the the
head of the hotel whatever it was were
you know he told John wick hey like
you're screwed like I think I can buy
you in Hauer but that's basically it
everybody's gonna come after you the guy
with the curly hair like the amazing
voice I wish I had his voice ah you
shaved that guy's head you sat me in a
wheelchair I think he'd be an amazing
Charles Xavier I really do think he
would because Ian McShane if he plays
the role correctly and if the role is
written correctly I think would make
make the the next best Charles Xavier
after Patrick Stewart because McShane
will be able to bring this kind of
persona to Xavier
where he's almost kind of mysterious
right like he's a guy who's there who
leaves the x-men but you're always kind
of left wondering what's he really
thinking like what's his real plan here
I think I think McShane could really
really do that like I think Ian McShane
could really really pull that off um
he's got the the he's got the kind of
persona where he sort of sits back and
it's not really one of these things were
like he's he's loud and obnoxious and
boorish because he needs people to know
he's in charge it's one of these things
where he's kind of like I'm in charge
here
like like you know it's it's one of
these scenes where he could put off the
impress
not so much that he needs to be heard
but if he has something to say he will
be hurt right like he can kind of be
that version of Charles Xavier that we
need especially when you're talking
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe
invoking the Illuminati which they will
you know in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe showing this kind of inner
circle of various people who have these
you know positions of authority and are
using it to safeguard the world and
operate behind the scenes and so on and
so forth I don't really know how they'll
do the Illuminati without without Tony
Stark but I'm sure they'll make it work
but the fact remains you know in my mind
I think Ian McShane is actually the best
choice to play the next version of
Charles Xavier but I don't know I mean
it really is a crapshoot you know it
really is one of these things where you
know actors have surprised us you know I
never would have picked Heath Ledger to
make a good Joker and look at him now
you're August look at look at the
version of the Joker now I mean I never
would have picked Chris Evans to be a
believable Captain America or for Robert
Downey jr. to like be a believable Iron
Man but there you go like I mean you get
these actors into these roles that you'd
never expect them to play and they pull
it off in spectacular fashion so again
it's it's interesting and it's actually
really really intriguing I'm curious
what's your all's Diggle I wouldn't know
what you're all staying what you're all
stances if you could pick one actor to
play Charles Xavier in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe who would you pick
I'm really curious to see what what
ideas you guys come up with but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you guys are new here
to comments explain make sure you all
hit the subscribe button to become part
of the robb core as you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]